Democrats pouncing on the Canadian smoke
monster smothering the East Coast as
another golden opportunity to lecture
Americans about climate change the
orange Haze and that's not named Donald
still billowing across the country and
could last for days the air right now is
harder to breathe and when Jesse sprays
on his air in the Green Room what yes
President Biden finally getting off his
butt to do something about it but didn't
sound too energized
spoke yesterday with prime minister
Trudeau
and I've decided to dictated a National
interagency Fire Center
response to Canada's request for
additional firefighters and the fire
suppression assets such as air tankers
trying to put the fire to sleep
meanwhile the climate change parrots are
chirping away more high price profile
Democrats using the wildfires to push
the issue a progressive congresswoman
says quote imagine being a republican
climate change denier in Congress you
show up to work at the Capitol today see
the skies filled with smoke and you
still don't get that we need bold and
immediate action to save our planet
ridiculous and despite the pollution
coming from Trudeau's trees in Canada
liberals still claim it's the Americans
who drive SUVs that are to blame
the climate crisis is real
and it is here to stay to say no it has
nothing to do with climate change is
naive obviously I'm no meteorologist
whether we're talking about wildfires or
storms there are going to be more
frequent more extreme if anybody has any
doubts uh this past couple of days and
what we're going to be dealing with for
the next few climate changes here these
kinds of weather phenomena are happening
all around the globe and it's only
becoming more and more common all
because of climate change with
increasing climate change and increasing
warming we can expect more and more of
these kind of wildfires so Martha one of
the things that is always amazing is
that people will state that though make
those statements and never follow up
with any data it's like and then the
pronounce pronouncements are not only
untethered to data but untethered to any
kind of practical solution at least
Smokey the Bear would tell you what to
do they just say we are in trouble we
need you know we need to bolt Solutions
and then they shut up it's crazy it's
crazy this has nothing to do with
climate change this issue it it it's
like hello
um put away the graphics it's like at
the climate change graphic up we have a
story that will definitely work for
um when you dig into this story you'll
learn that it's really about the
forestation process the fact that they
haven't been able to do these kind of
prescribed Burns that they need in order
to it's the same problem that has
happened in California and one of the
things that really strikes me now is
that the it's no longer there's no
longer environmentalism that is driving
people who care about the Earth it's not
about environmentalism because if it was
then you would have people taking care
of the forest because they would be
concerned about the animals that live
there you have to go and you have to
clear out all the underbrush all the
dead growth you have to make sure the
trees grow you have to do the logging
that's required in order to keep the
forest healthy and I see this in so many
ways it's just all about oil
if it doesn't have to do with oil then
they don't care about it at all that's
why we have wind turbines that are
threatening the whale populations that's
why we have cars that are being built
with batteries that have toxic things in
them that no one knows how to get rid of
it at the end but it doesn't matter
because it's about the oil and the gas
so it's become so myopic that they're
kind of forgetting I think about Teddy
Roosevelt and even Robert Kennedy Jr who
talks about actually cleaning up the
rivers and real environmentalism which
appears to be lost just throw up the
climate change graphic and we're good I
know it you know that it's a good point
about RFK Jr because when he talks about
environmentalism he talks like somebody
who actually uses the environment that
he loves the Earth meanwhile almost all
these activists don't do anything right
they don't they spend all their time
indoors like you Jesse are you saying
Joy Reid's never been camping I don't
think well you know what I don't think
she's never been canoeing backpacking
splunking do you know what that is yes
but it's cave exploration
environmentalism true environmentalism
has been replaced by ideology you could
be a democrat or a republican but not
anymore well and also it's about money
too so if you want some statistics yeah
from 1706 to 1910 there have been 20
so-called dark days or yellow days where
the average people they don't have TV
back then go out and then at noon it's
dark or it's yellow and these are
phenomenon that have happened over the
last 200 years well before the
automobile so this is normal and what
they're doing is they're preying on
ignorance not everybody knows that
burning forests from Canada has blacked
out North America
dozens and dozens of times over the last
300 years they're banking on people not
knowing that I I talked to my
meteorological sources and they said
that there are normal temperatures in
Canada normal precipitation in Canada
there has been ordinary weather in May
in Canada this is not some extreme hot
winds that that has taken over Canada
this is a normal Canadian June that
because of lightning strikes and campers
that put out their camels in a in a dry
bed of of poorly managed forests that's
what's happening and so Joe Biden's
taking advantage of this to push the
green New Deal so people like his donors
can get paid and not people like Exxon
Mobil that usually donate to Republicans
you know Harold in the green room I was
shocked when you said that you believe
these Wildfire fires were started by the
burning of banned books from Florida
uh I thought we were going to keep that
conversation too so
um I bet you have a different look
Outlook on this topic no no I I
largely in line I would I would say the
forest management issue is a serious
issue
um but what we can't deny also I think
is you that the data that you present
there Jesse 1706 I think to 1910 I think
it'd be interesting is to look from
2005 to
2023 the increasing frequency in which
we're seeing some of these occurrences
now we can do well they're actually down
we talked about that last night over the
last hundred years these forest fires
are down from about four percent to
about 2.5 percent worldwide so the
occurrences of droughts which contribute
to the reason I think we need some of
this Force management my only point is I
think we can do both two things can be
right at once even if it causes a little
tension or consternation we should be
doing both of these things to the extent
that it makes sense meaning is it
economically viable uh I I would agree I
think Martha you're right some Democrats
who are critical of these things and
want to raise the climate change issue
were really doing it because of a an
aversion to fossil fuels which I don't
have uh but I understand where they're
coming from but I always try to try to
try to figure out the core of someone's
answer and even if I don't like some of
their motivations there's no doubt
Forest management is a problem the
occurrences of these kind of weather
abnormalities are increasing uh that now
the the quotes you you told yesterday I
think some Democrats would find that
uncomfortable to know that there were
dark days back in the 1700s and there
were no combustible engines that we'd be
kidding ourselves if we don't believe
that we are contributing to uh the ozone
layer depletion we'd be can we'd be
kidding ourselves if we're saying well
whatever it is whether you agree we are
not something is and I think we've got
to try to figure that out and while we
try to figure it out even if we can't
agree on it we ought to agree on steps
we can take to try to reverse it Forest
management has to be a part of it and we
have to get serious about wondering why
are these droughts occurring why are
hurricanes more likely or likely are
happening across the country if that
matter why are we having these weather
abnormalities across the country these
are questions I think public policy
makers should be thinking about it if
they can subtract out some of the some
of the politics but the problem here
judge is that if they do actually have
some kind of meeting of the minds then
all of these activists are out of a job
right you have they have to have this
they have to have this Us Versus Them
thing everything is about us versus them
you can talk about spaghetti in a
supermarket and they'll figure out some
way to divide it into it yeah
okay but you know what yeah
but the the thing is if these
environmentalists I mean it's not just
the environmentals right the climate
change is the latest pretty issue that
we're going to dump billions into we've
already dumped the billions into but if
they're so concerned about the
environment you know what they what
they're saying is you know that that
they they're not involved in the
controlled Burns where you get rid of
the underbrush to Martha's Point what
you were talking about the United States
in order to protect forests and to take
care of that those areas that are in
danger of burning we've done a hundred
and fifty thousand control burns okay do
you know how many Canada's done 12 23.
okay Michael Jordan Canada is just like
Gavin Newsom in terms of how he was
handling Forest management and then they
want to believe it all on climate change
it's not about climate change it's about
your ability to see what's going on and
to prevent it and maybe they don't want
to do any of this because they want to
save the spiders who are under the wood
who are under the ground in case they
have a controlled burn but let me tell
you one more thing this reminds me of
Palestine Ohio that we have moved on
from we suffer for two days and we're
all in a tizzy right these people in
Palestine Ohio suffered and will
continue to suffer and they've been
forgotten okay and the last thing I want
to say is this Joe Biden gets up there
and he says uh we're gonna put together
a national personal interagency fire
response to work with Canada no you're
the president of the United States they
have done something that has harmed
people in the United States another
president would have said what are you
doing to stop this why is this happening
this is a serious health hazard for the
people in my country but what does Biden
do he joins the wrongdoing he creates
this ideological issue and says well put
more money in it our money there you go
I I'm old enough to remember 10 minutes
ago when she said she didn't know what
she was going to say today
I didn't
do trees have a gender
we can give them one no it's just I'm
just curious is there he she or are they
non-binary some of them don't have
because that's where the money should go
yeah like have you ever had like a
gardenia tree some of them don't blossom
in some of them do another one though
like two Holly trees you have to have
two right to get them to yeah you know
how it works there you go yes you got an
opinion on this well I just saw one time
there was a tree that like grew into
another tree right and they tangled up
yeah
yeah all right hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else